the takeaway from all of this is that
the russian advance
is starting it's fairly slow we've had
some uh information in the last couple
of hours that the village that we were
in alexandrevka has now been taken by
russian forces we saw the beginning
of that attack the ukrainian soldiers
there
that we spoke to they managed to
evacuate those places now there is a
patchwork
of these small farming type villages
across the line of contact at the moment
which is moving uh south from those
russian positions they did manage to get
people out
but it is moving forward but that said
the russians are at risk
from
a counter-attack a ukrainian
counter-attack we saw a large number
of ukrainian soldiers we also saw quite
a lot of heavy weaponry
as well and they are very confident that
they can win this war
particularly of course with the support
that they are getting uh many countries
around the world are now sending in
heavy weapons uh to this area to try to
stop that russian invasion uh in the in
its tracks now they are also boys
because
they've seen the botched russian
offensive in the north of the country
down here where i am in the donbass they
are also familiar with this enemy
they're familiar with the tactics this
is a war that remember has been uh
running now one way or another since
2014 so for eight years but of course
the big big fear is for people still
trapped uh where i am and it seems that
the russian forces are trying to
encircle the donbass in a kind of pincer
movement to cut off ukrainian forces
these are some of the most skilled and
experienced uh ukrainian soldiers but
there are quite a few civilians still
trapped here and the fear of course is
that they will get caught in the
crossfire of this fighting